[Music]
foreign
[Music]
as a firefighter back in 1989 the
majority of his job was focused on fire
rescue however in recent years his job
has expanded
in recent years new houses in bangkok
have been built in areas where snakes
were more common
which means snakes are slithering their
way into houses on a more regular basis
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the rally's palm pit viper and
it's as dangerous as it is rare
there are 10 species of palm pit viper
that inhabit the cloud forests of
central america
but of all of them the rallies is the
most rare and elusive
it can only be found on three isolated
mountains in southern mexico
brilliant green and slender these vipers
will spend most of their lives coiled
quietly in trees and other vegetation
they are not aggressive by nature but
will strike if disturbed
a bite from a rallies is not likely to
be fatal to humans but be warned
no specific antivenom exists for this
extraordinary species of snake
while not necessarily a threat to us
those that should be worried are the
small mammals and tree frogs that the
viper preys upon
those that stray too close will meet a
swift and silent end
but even these venomous predators can't
stave off bigger threats
deforestation and over-collection for
the pet trade are perilous threats for
this rare animal
this is the rally's palm pit viper
this is the massasauga rattlesnake
it is ontario's only venomous snake but
it's more scared of humans than we are
of it
massasaugas aren't very large growing up
to three feet in length
their skin is grey to dark brown dappled
with darker splotches along its back
their tails rattle as a warning yet they
won't strike unless they have no choice
that's because massive sagas are shy and
prefer to hide than bite their enemies
unfortunately they can't hide from
encroaching human development which
combined with intentional killings from
over-exaggerated fear have caused a
large decline in its canadian population
this is the massasauga rattlesnake
[Music]
the snake oil salesman the phrase is
often used to characterize grifters and
con artists but where did the saying
come from
well the story starts in the 1800s
chinese immigrants working on the first
transcontinental railroad would rub
snake oil on their skin to treat joint
pain
westerners eventually caught on and
marveled at its apparent healing powers
while some admired it others saw
opportunity
in comes clark rattlesnake king stanley
he was a self-proclaimed cowboy and
so-called expert in traditional native
american medicine
looking to make a quick buck he teamed
up with a boston druggist and began
marketing clark stanley's snake oil
liniments the miracle medicine promised
to heal your rheumatism neuralgia
sciatica lame back lombago toothache
sore throat animal bites gungan disease
alright that last one isn't real but who
cares this sucker would fix anything
that ale did
clark took his product on the road
visiting fairs and put on elaborate
spectacles in front of a hungry crowd
during one show he squeezed a snake to
death and bottled up its residue while
some were mesmerized others were
skeptical
after seeing the injustices made to
public health famous muckraker samuel
hopkins adams investigated the
fraudulent patent medicine industry and
wrote the watershed expose the great
american fraud this led to the federal
government seizing a shipment of the
snake oil and analyzing it they found
out that it was made of mostly just
mineral oil the quack medicine industry
came to an end when the pure food and
drug act was passed
the fed slapped clark with a 20 fine and
he promptly closed up shop
though samuel exposed the frauds clark
stanley had the last laugh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a louisiana pine snake if we
didn't show it to you you'd probably
never see it or its distinct yellow and
brown splotch scales
it's one of the rarest snakes in north
america
the louisiana pine snake can grow up to
six feet long it's not poisonous it's a
constrictor it wraps its prey and
suffocates them
its known habitat is estimated to be
less than 200 square miles in the
longleaf pine forests on the louisiana
texas border
a habitat that is only three percent of
its once massive size
it's almost impossible to spot in the
wild because the snake spends its time
below ground moving through the tunnels
of its rodent prey
but when it pokes its head above ground
its habitat is in steady decline
fewer trees mean fewer rodents barring
beneath and that means fewer pine snakes
and with encroaching human development
the ever-present threat of being crushed
under road traffic looms
this is louisiana pine snake
so we have about 500 venomous snakes in
the serpentine
avid of any of these venomous snakes
could kill you that's why we're working
here we are collecting venoms to prevent
them
[Music]
my name is aron gomez i'm the
coordinator of the segmentary so this is
a central american coral snake you get
beat you can stop breathing and die
this is a neotropical rattlesnake if
bites you you can die after several
minutes
[Music]
so it's estimated that around 800 000 to
1 million people are getting bitten by
venomous snakes every year
we need snakes in order to produce
anti-venom there are no many labs making
that anti-venom just like six
we estimate to produce around 100 000
vials per year
[Music]
so we
handle the snake we apply some massage
in the muscles of the head and then we
collect the venom in this kind of
special flask
then we process the venom we press dry
and then we collect the venom in powder
form
and that venom is going to use to
produce the anti-venom
if you get this by a viper or a coral
snake in america or in central america
the chances that you're getting
anti-venom produced by institute are
very very high this is terciopello and
this one can kill you like drop that
kill you most of the people just fear
their snakes let's say that i'm not
afraid but i have respect of the snake
and you've never been bad i never made
me thank god
[Music]
meet onyx a five-year-old eastern indigo
snake
[Music]
at nine feet in length eastern indigos
are considered to be the longest native
snakes in the united states
even though they lack a venomous bite
they can fall victim to overzealous
rattlesnake hunters as they inhabit the
same burrows
their beautiful smooth scaled skin is a
shade of bluish black
carnivorous like all snakes onyx feeds
on any small animal she can overpower
onyx may hiss or rattle her tail when
alarmed but she'll hardly ever bite like
most snakes humans are their biggest
threat as continued urbanization has
left them threatened throughout parts of
the united states
this is the eastern indigo snake
this is the giant garter snake
they are endemic to the central valley
wetlands of california and considered an
aquatic species but with the loss of
wetlands in the region the gardea snake
is no longer found in 98 of the areas it
once resided in
[Music]
considered the largest of the garda
snake family they can grow to be more
than five feet long
[Music]
while they are venomous creatures they
pose no risk to humans
their mild venom subdues its prey which
consists mainly of fission frogs
these snakes are brown or olive colored
but can easily be spotted by their
yellow stripes
they are secretive and difficult to
approach and are known to dive into
water before an observer can get too
close
[Music]
conservation efforts to create
artificial wetlands are underway to try
and restore their dwindling populations
this is the giant gardener snake
you